in sudan the government says it has
prevented an attempted coup the
authorities say those responsible are
linked to ousted leader omar al-bashir
tanks were spotted on the roads of the
capital city and a number of suspected
plotters were arrested state-run media
announced the coup had failed and that
order has been restored but some
journalists have reported that parts of
the city are not yet entirely under
government control sudan has been ruled
by a joint military and civilian council
since al-bashir was overthrown two years
ago
for more on this story i'm now jane
joined by collude cair political analyst
at inside strategy partners who's based
in khartoum but happens to be in london
this week collude what more do you know
about this attempted coup
well gerhard we're still getting more
information through as this is a
developing ongoing issue what we do know
so far are that the coup plotters are
all
highly ranked members of the sudan armed
forces they are all ranked or major
general colonel or higher
at 7 00 am this morning there was an
attempt to infiltrate the um the
state-run broadcaster asking them to
play marching music
military anthems usually synonymous with
uh coups bearing in mind this is sudan's
third post um dictatorship transition
and if history is to repeat itself we
are heading towards another military
coup obviously forces in sudan civilian
forces in sudan the civilian government
civil society are very much against this
but history is very much on the military
side the poo plot was aimed at
controlling the general command radio
television bridges
and then to arrest all members of the
ruling sovereign council and the council
of ministers or the cabinet um of course
the the coup has uh failed as you've
mentioned and so bridges are now opened
and some streets are back to normal
we're awaiting a joint statement from
the government and the forces for
freedom and change which is the civilian
umbrella
notably the military has yet to release
a statement um and i think they're
waiting to sort of see where the public
public opinion lies on this uh political
parties have come out very much against
this and many are saying that this could
be a test or a message or both from
remnants of bashir's um supporters still
within the military
let me interrupt you uh here they what
has the political situation been like in
sudan in recent months has this been
foreseeable somehow
there are certainly many who have said
we're on our way to another coup
certainly history um
would agree with that statement and it
is very true that politically things
have been very fraught the transitional
government was formed almost two years
ago exactly and this civilian military
alliance was always going to be
uncomfortable after 30 years of military
rule um but the transition itself
suffers from a lack of consensus-driven
politics in agreement about and you know
agreement about how to implement key
transitional documents like the
constitutional document and the juba
peace agreement um there are obviously
difficulties within the imbalance
between the civilian and military wings
of the government and this has caused a
lot of problems um for the cabinet and
for the prime minister abdullah
particularly in being able to implement
his transitional agenda
in the background of all this there are
very acute domestic and international
crises um on the border with ethiopia
domestically the economic situation is
very dire
and this has people to believe that a
cool um or at least very uh serious
political change is imminent
clue here political analyst at inside
strategy partners thank you very much
for your time
thank you